Oh, this is the crap
uncommon. But this might be my new
favorite deck. New favorite
deck. Hello, this is June from Next
Level Commander and recently I did a
7hour session brainstorming every single
Final Fantasy multiolor legend and a
crap uncommon I called it ended up
becoming my favorite commander from the
set. And here is the live footage. Next
up, we have Zade. Tentilus
thief, human mutant scout. How is he a
mutant? I don't see
it. Was that a
tail? Oh, it's like a
monkey. Okay, this is Yeah, this is like
the kind of character that lives in the
forest. He lived in a jungle all his
life and then somehow is more sociable,
less socially awkward than the entire
main character group.
uncommon. Uh when Zenang enters, gain
control of target creature and opponent
controls. On tap, it gains lifelink and
haste. Whenever an opponent gains
control of a permanent from you, you
create a treasure
token. This is not
good. This is not good. It's like the
Zedru deck. It's like the donate
archetype or the act of treason deck.
But the problem is the payoff is
nothing. You get a treasure for all
that. At least give me one card. You
draw a card. Why can't I draw a card? If
I If I can draw a card, this is
buildable. You can act of treason. They
can trip. You can donate
things. Oh boy. What do we
do? If we do active treason tribal, so
we steal something every turn and then
we give it back just to smack
someone. And then we're defenseless. We
have our treasures to
block. Oh.
This is the crap uncommon of the
set. Give me I don't want to give up.
Give me like 30 seconds. This is
interesting.
But I guess we have
to because I know the act of treason
ability is much more powerful at instant
speed. So would a blink deck be a thing?
Like you blink it. Yeah. is so much
better when you do it in your opponent's
turn or or you have you threaten to do
it on your opponent's turn, but I don't
think we have enough instantly blinks to
make it
work. Basically, during combat, your
opponent will think that you always have
a blink. So, that one, your commander is
protected, and two, they can't attack
you because they attack you, you take
the strongest
creature and block with it, and you end
up with more life than you. You started,
and they lose their biggest creature.
That's that's really nice. That's really
good. Okay, maybe Yeah, maybe this is a
thing. But the problem is we cannot do
slow blink. Slow blink doesn't do
anything with Z,
right? Yeah, because you don't return it
till the end of turn. So, slowblink
doesn't do anything. So, it has to be
the immediate blink. And I doubt we will
have find we'll find enough, but we will
try. I hope I'm wrong. I hope I'm wrong.
Blink exile
return. Pretty
sure pipeline we will not restrict the
type. We will search with
these.
Yep. Slow uh fast blink. This is a slow
blink. I saw number sure you control
return those cart that's slow blink slow
blink fast
blink a fast blink oh we have some
decent ones
actually mimic that today
no fast blink touch the spirit
realm semester's end this is a slow
blink I believe yes
yes acrobatics is this a slow blink This
can be a a slow link. No, we don't want
that. Flicker of Fate. Good card. Yeah,
it's dropping in equality real fast. We
only have five. This might not work.
Ooh, a frozy
displacer. Parting Gust is a great card,
but it's a it's a slow blink. No, that's
it. Ghost way. Slow blink. Aldrazi
confluence. This is a blink. Okay. You
can also create a token and choose you
may choose the same mode more than once.
Oh, you cannot win twice. But you can
Yeah, you can blink or remove something.
Make to Yeah, this is good. Beggars can
be choosers. Just remember to play some
colorless
lands. What does this do? Exile. Oh,
please be a fast.
Nope. Slow blink. Slow
blink. Fast blink. Oh, we have No, not
not quite. We need more. We need more.
Slow
blink. Oh, this deck needs a
feather. Well, I'm so glad feather came
up with a
search cuz I would never I would never
thought of maybe I would have, but
probably
not. Oh, please just give me Let's see.
Give me one,
two, five more. I need five or six more
blinks. Slow blink. N sorcery. Sorcery.
Scroll shift. Ah,
good. I forgot about these countries.
There's one more. There's one more.
Well, you can't do it. Jazz hourglass
pendant. If a player will be extra turn,
that player skips the turn instead.
Uh, no. Yes. Fast
blink.
Uh,
okay.
Nice. Flicker Form. I forgot about this
card. Wait. Yes. Okay. We I mean we
don't have that many that that can
trigger a feather, but I still think
it's good cuz we just need one blinking
spell in hand for feather to go nuts.
Kind of two is better, but just one
astral drift. When you
cycle, you ex Oh, it's good. It's
good. Oh, and stop. Why? Get away
glamour. No, against all odds, please.
No, that's not even a blink spell. Other
worldly. I know it's a slow
blink. Ah, Pegasus exile target creature
control every turn. Nice. It's even Oh,
it's even payoff for for
blinking. We have I think we have a
deck. I think we have a deck. Long roll
doesn't
work. Astro Slide.
No. Whenever. Uh, no.
Morland Parallax Wave. This card is
sweet.
Yeah, because you can just pay four
meta, hold it, and then blink any number
of creatures. Well, blink up to five
creatures, right? And you don't need to
target five. You can just target sedane
five times if you just want to blink
sedane. You only get one blink, but you
can in a pinch, you can use it. And you
can remove five things like someone's
attacking you. You fog
basically or you Oh, I think we are
making a blink
deck. We will see. We will see because
what else are we putting to the deck?
Blink,
right? Stonecloaker angel. Oh, is this
No. Oh, another restoration angel.
Yes. Disguise doesn't do
anything. I think that's it. Oh no,
there's an old border. There's an old
card. What's it called? I forgot. We
have to find it. We have to find it.
Okay, this deck I think we might be
going deep with this one. So maybe I'll
leave a time stamp for the next deck if
you want to skip it. Yeah, I will
because this might take a little while.
We are two hours in and this is peak and
I well again I'm maybe speaking too
early. We'll see. But I have a good
feeling about this. Choose another heart
creature. Control exalt.
No.
Joshua, nice to see you
again. Coin of Fate. I saw two creature
cards from No. No. Where's that old
card? If I can remember the name, I can
It's not here. It's called Snappers.
It's not called Snap. Someone help me.
Strange. Maybe I'll find it later. But
uh for now, we are going to look for
also red clone spells.
that can clone Zedane but only instance.
I'm not sure if there's any, but we
don't want to miss it if there is. So,
uh,
copy target
creature. Copy
creature inferno.
No, it's
not copy creature. Yeah, I don't think
there's copying target creature in in
red white instant speed. So, we have 19
cards and all of them blink
almost. I think this is
fine. And we want to because it's we
have feather. We also want a Mav Mar
Marvin Mav Mavinda Mavinda's
card.
Yes, because in Boros we have to, you
know, get the value. We are not getting
too much card
advantage. Now I think we are looking
for blink targets. What other synergy is
there? Gain
control. Oh. Oh. Oh. Stiltken. We can
play
stiltkin because we can give some
opponent's cards to what's it called?
Stilt. We can donate someone's card to
another person. Stiltskin. Sorry.
Stiltskin. Target opponent gain control
of another target control. Yeah. And
then you pay two to give them that card.
Nice. Usually we'll do this with
commanders. Just swap their commanders
with each other. And yeah, now we're
looking for enter the battlefield cards.
enter the
battlefield. We don't want to play too
many. We want to play a few that we can
just keep linking
and win the game. Hopefully, they can
win the game for us. But we'll
see. We will
see. Sometime sometime worth
it. Probably not.
Wait, is it a com? No, it's not a combo
with this, but Karma
Guide. Yeah.
Yeah. Sky Cleave Operation. See, this is
This card is good, but I don't think
it's worth a blink cuz blink spells are
We don't have that many. I mean, we have
a few. We want to save it for other
things. We'll if we don't have enough
targets, good targets, we will come
back.
But uh enduring
innocence problem is we probably don't
have a lot of two power things. We'll
see. Is the marri shepherd good enough?
I think it might be like it's not ETB,
but we want to keep it on the board just
because just because it's so much value
when we
landfall. I think it's worth it.
Um, Hellkai Corser and this
creature.
Oh, so with this on the field, I can
just blink this. I don't even need to.
It will bring in Zedane and
then Zedane will
leave. Oh, okay. It's like another
Zedane basically.
It's not super powerful, but the
interaction is funny. And it's I mean,
six mana is a good card. You can blink
it. Oh, that's really cool. I like it.
Gandalf, what does what does he do?
Nothing. Flash legendary creatures.
Legendary artifact trigger. Oh, double
trigger. Artifact leaving double. I
think that's kind of worth it.
Well, I have to see if we have other
legendary creatures. Uh, maybe not
really. Oh, but with Gandalf, you have
flash with Gandalf on tap and then you
can Zedane. You blink Zane twice. It's
like immediate
insurrection. Entering or leaving?
Entering or leaving? We'll see. We'll
see. Okay.
Aerial Extortionist interest deals
combat exile target nonline
permanent. Okay, this is the card we
This is the kind of removal card we
need. Yeah, sweet. Draws us cards. We
need card draw. Gold gets us an
equipment. I don't think we want
equipments cuz we're blinking unless
it's No, it's not worth it. Yes, this is
the card we
need. Uh, Angel Serenity, by the way.
Yeah, because some of you maybe can't
see my mouse
going. Yeah, you can remove, you can
recur, that's everything. Abdo, what
does Abdull do? Exile any number until
it leaves. So, you can
exile. It's too slow, I
think. Sam wise, I'm I'm going fast
because these are small cards are small.
Probably don't do much. Angel of
indemnity, mana
four, mana value
four. I think it's worth it. I think
it's good. I mean, unfortunately, for
some reason, our commander is five mana.
I mean, this can be four mana, right? I
guess it's too good and limited,
but fine.
Arbaz champion of minus
ter enters the battlefield. You choose
monarch. You become monarch and it's a
propaganda blinking. This we do want
monarch in the game. We do because it's
difficult for our opponents to target
us. But this ability is not what we
need. It's fine, but it's not we we'll
hold it. If we can't find other good
Monarch cards, we might include this.
But I feel like Red White is pretty good
for Monarch, right? Glorious
Protector until it leaves. Now, this is
like a slow
blink, but can be used as a fast blink
if we have
sacks. Kind of like I kind of want to
play
this now.
How does it work? So, I have a board and
then I flash this in for four
mana. It exalts my board and
now I can just use blink spell on the
angel and it's like blinking everything.
Is that right? And then I protect my
board. Is that right? I think so.
Whoa, that's super good, isn't
it? Let me double check. Okay, you blink
the angel. Everything comes in, trigger
CTB, and then the angel comes back to
exile everything again. Oh, this is
nuts. I also want that. Oh, yeah. I was
like, I missed it. But I also want that
card. This card, right? Because the same
thing when it enters exile any
number create a token for each one and
then you blink it everything comes in
you get to
Oh okay we have a deck
boys. Oh honestly I'm sorry lightning
but this might be my new favorite
deck. I'll have to play it to see but
this looks sweet on
paper. World are we brave enough? No, we
are not. We're not going to world
gorge. What does this do? Scamp. No, not
going to read it. Redemption choir.
Redemption choir enters. If you control
three or more creatures, different power
return. No. Glory rise. Return all human
creatures. Today is a human. What other
human do we
have? Probably not worth it. But exile
all
zombies. What if? Just what if?
No, it's not worth
it. Essence of
orthodoxy.
No. Bill. What's Bill do? Make two
fruits. Motor load. Mother
load.
Creatures control the bust was two
sentinel Sarah
Leon's two creatures to
talk number of artifacts controlled.
No, I think how many cards do we have?
We have 29 cards. Not that many. So I
think there's still
room. But how many blank targets do we
have? Have like five or six good ones.
There's one I have in mind. There's one
I have in mind. It's like
a Oh, is this good? Trove
warden. No, but the one I have in mind
is the the primordial molten primordial.
I think that when it enters, you just
steal two things or one from each
opponent actually, which is really good.
Until we get to that, I I would I'm
willing to believe that there's other
quality cards waiting for
us. What does the Buzz Crusher do?
Destroy land. No, doesn't do
enough. Twilight
Shepherd
Ash Lomb Battle one exile number of
notable creatures. Oh, it's the same
thing. Do we want another one of these?
I don't think we need another one of
these. Two is enough because it's kind
of a a bit of a win more card. Like it's
nuts once you get it set,
but also there's not much payoff with
this one. So, I'll skip it for now. Salt
skitter comes into play removed.
No.
Shepherd. The quality is dropping.
Clive. What does Clive do? Discards your
hand. Draw equal to your devotion to
red.
So, we can discard our hand and draw a
minimum
of three, assuming Zane is in play. What
other red permanence do we have? We
don't have many. Let's see the backside,
although it's probably not relevant. It
is not relevant. Okay. Uh, bishop of
binding. Nope. No, no, no.
Idolon. Oh, we can have
constellation. Don't think it's good
here.
Boom weaver giant interest. Search your
battlefield aura card. Put it on the
battlefield. Attached to boom. It has to
be attached to boom weaver. What auras
do we have? Cuz I don't want it. The
only aura is the what's it called?
Flicker form. But I want that on today.
So no. Fear of
abduction. Leaves the battlefield. Exalt
harder opponent control. No. Not good.
Sagardian Savior value my value too.
Nope. General Leo.
Oh, okay. I'm pretty close to just
searching for that card. Don't think
we're Yeah, don't don't don't think
we're getting House Molten Primordial
Soul. Nobody plays that card. Card is
nuts. Card is like one of the Okay,
maybe not one of the best, but it's a
pretty good aggro card, I'd say. Okay,
let's find
it. Molten.
Prime ore
deal. It's sweet, right? You get to
steal three creatures. You get alpha
strike people and then you get what?
Three
treasures. So now we have 30 cards. And
of course we need some ramp. I might as
well get might as well go there. We need
some ramp. Uh,
Boros
add
artifact cuz Zing is five mana. Five
mana is a lot. We want to be able to get
Zedane out and hold a blink spell as
soon as
possible. So, Soul Ring, is this a deck
for
Sunforger? I don't think so. It's what
two to uh Sunforger. It's a bit
expensive and all we have is Blink
spells. So, I'm sure we have to play
some more moves,
but probably not
enough. Mind stone, commander sphere.
Sphere is good. Yeah,
sure. Roaming
throne.
Yes. Yes, we want
that.
Wait. And we can even change the
creature type by blinking it. Not good.
How many humans do we have? It's just
the dang. If it's just the dang, it
might not be worth
it. Yeah. You know what? I don't think
just getting one or two. I don't really
need I just need one steel to shut off
to shut down most combat attempts
against
us. So,
uh sorry, man rocks animal too too big.
Uh, cursed mirror is sick. Cursed mirror
is one of the best man. Warm power storm
is
fine. Relic legends. This is good
because when you get blinked like the
can tap for mana and then you blink it,
you can tap lower mana. So this I think
is good. Okay, we should play more but
for now we will just put these. And next
next uh 37 cards. We really we
desperately need some card advantage
card draw.
So, how are we drawing cards in Boros?
We
are monarch. Let's because again we are
shutting down combat. We're trying to
shut down
combat. So, let's try to take monarch.
Although your opponents can probably
send, you know, two or three small
things at you
and take the monarch and then it's
difficult for us to take it back. We'll
see if we have any monarch good monarch
cards. Champion is hopefully not the
best
one.
Court Skyland is it's fine. Ember Wild
Captain. I guess it's like a backup
punishment like for attacking us. I
think this one is fine. I think the
courts are good. Fourth. No. Yeah, I
don't think we want the quartz just
because again because if we get enough
payoff from the monarch, your opponents
will try to take it and then it's like
difficult for us. We have three2
attacking us. Do we do we use Zane or
not?
Um
so Impalis Palace Palace Jailer no
Eommer Aom king of
Rohan double strike when it
enters put okay when enters target
player becomes monarch Aom deals damage
equal to its power I don't think this is
that
good yeah
no archon Coronation interest becomes
monarch. As long as you're a monarch,
then dam it doesn't cost
lives. Don't think it's super
amazing. Unfortunately, we are going to
have to wait. Is this good? Except card
sacrifice artifact one uses two. No,
it's not
good. Unfortunately, we have to find
other ways. I was thinking, what about
humble
defector? Humble defector.
So you can steal it. You can steal this
with
Zedang and then give it again to draw
two cards. So but the problem is you're
playing you're expending one blink spell
to draw two
cards. In a pinch it's decent, but then
you're also helping your opponents and
knowing your shenanigans, your opponents
are probably not going to pass the
defector to
you, right?
Maybe we can play like a mini package
with homework
path. Maybe maybe because I just
remember there's another humble defector
in white, but I forgot the name. It's
from
Fallout.
Fallout. It's a ro Yes man or something.
Yes
man. Oh, it is. It is. Yes. Okay. Okay.
Target opponent gets control of target.
If yes man personal something secure
securatron. Yeah. What they do? You draw
two cards and put a quest counter. When
Yesman leaves the owner create. Okay.
This is this is
good. So we play Yesman. And then we
have to have a homework path
package because that's what makes it
worth worth doing. We don't want to
waste our blink spells to draw the two
cards. Now we need things to search for
lands. Search for
land pipeline. Anything red,
white.
Whoops. Too late. Let's try
again. I do know about weather wafer
which will be in this deck, but anything
else we can search for lands with. Nope.
No, no. These are all basic lands. Basic
lands. Basic lands. There's Öza's cave.
I think I can search
for search. No, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no. Oh, this one searches for Yep.
Basic land. Basic land. Basic
land
wafer. Moon silver key searches for
artifact or a basic. Basic escape
tunnel. No.
Why I want none
basic. Well, I'm also looking for uh
expedition map.
So, oh also my favorite card, Theatic
Compass. My third favorite card. And uh
because we are operating mostly at
instant speed, so we can afford to
activate this a lot. And yeah, again
getting land drops and also eventually
getting
amazer gift hawk. Basic basic basic
basic. Did I skip this cave? Not
yet. Okay, I think I know what I'm
looking for. So I'm just going to search
for
them. The first one is called expedition
map.
Boom. And then
Öza
cave. Beautiful. All right. And we have
43 nonland cards. We still need more
card draw. We will see what options we
have. We're going to draw cards. Draw a
card. Can't be too ambitious here. Draw
a card. Typeline. Doesn't matter.
Colors. White or red.
Go. Think we're going to need some cards
like death for
Sentinel. Smothering tithe. We don't
really need the one
ring. We are pretty desperate for card
draw. Maybe. Maybe it's good. War Room.
Yes,
absolutely. Now, do we want this card?
We don't really have any synergy with
this card, I don't think. So, no.
Idol. Nope. Vanquisher
whenever cast a creature spell. Nope.
Minus.
Nope. Lauren. It's a blank target and it
draws his
cards. It's not the best, but I think
once again we are in Boros. Beggars
can't be choosers. We don't have enough
creatures to trigger this. I don't think
enough small
creatures. So, no. Seram.
No. Valic Awakening. Sure. Card
filtering is
good. Whenever archavist of all whenever
opponent searches can't really rely on
that. Do we wheel? I don't think we
do. Wheel is pretty wheels are pretty
extreme. I'd say I don't think
so. Rep. No. Mangara. Opponent attacks
with two creatures attacking you. You
draw a card. This is not going to happen
much, but whenever opponent casts their
second spell turn, draw a card. This is
nuts, right? I guess I'll draw a lot of
cards. This is close to trouble to
trouble in pairs, which I will also
play. Should I keep track of game
changers? We have like three,
two,
whatever. We can adjust later. Throne of
fraas welcome. One or more creatures you
control manifest three or less. Draw a
card.
No, no, no, no, no. Gear Hulk. I don't I
don't think this is good cuz your
opponent will just take the damage. It's
like five damage to one
opponent. Unless your play group is
super greedy, I don't think anyone will
let you draw. So, no gear
hook shield whenever Oh, it's artifact
creatures. Okay, never mind. Cut a deal.
Each opponent draws a card. Then you
draw a card for each opponent who drew
this
play. This and the secret rendevous from
earlier from this
set. Do we play them? We might just have
to play them cuz the stuff we're doing
is really powerful. We want gas. We want
gas. Excuse me. Secret. No, no, no. This
is not the one from Oh, this is Sorry.
This is not from the new set, but it's
in the new set.
Yeah.
Jaxis, create a token that's copy of
target creature you
control. Activate as sorcer sorcery.
No, this one coveted
jewel again. This is like monarch
where yeah, I don't think we can defend
it too well. We can defend our life
total well, but not our not our jewel.
Derer more
more angel.
No zoolologist.
No, I think this is it for now. Right.
This one smuggler share is not not that
amazing. Yeah, I think this is it for
now. We have 54. We are pretty close to
completing the deck. Of course, we need
some removals and board wipes, right? We
need everyone. Everyone needs that. So,
uh I I'll
just Yeah, I'll just do it
manually. Chaos
warp
path. Do we play
paths? Exile swords flasher. Boros. Do
we defer
protection? We're going all in. We are
We are going bracket four with
this. Uh it's the best removal
path. I still think it's Yeah, I think
still think path and swords are worth
it. That was a bad idea. That was not a
good idea. Path two. Sorry. Path to
exile. Don't be
lazy.
Really? Are you seriously? No way. This
is No way this is
true. A path to
E. Oh my
gosh. There you go. Thank
you. Swords to plow shares. I swear.
Okay, good. Generous gift.
Maybe we want some slow blink just to
protect our board. I was just thinking
maybe what's that card called? Eerie
interlude. Yeah, cuz the only our only
weakness here is board wipe, right? We
are pretty protected from most spot
rules, but fast blink you you don't
Yeah, you don't dodge word wipes. So,
what's the other one called? Ghost.
Ghost way, I think. Ghost
way. Okay, let's play two of
these. And
then board wipes. What are the best
board
wipes?
Farewell. Farewell is a game changer,
but we're going deep. And also I think
the best one next to variable is the one
the instant speed one
called called
called with escalate. Can't remember but
we'll find it. Escalate. Yeah, we're
just building this
deck.
Escalade.
Escalate. Whoops. It is not escalate.
It's spree. Sorry.
Tip timeline
instant destroy text spree and
destroy. That should give us the
card
destroy final final showdown. Yes, it's
called final showdown. And what are
there any creature board
wipes
like destroy? Oh, I'm going to give it a
try.
destroy
all because if there is this is
nuts. Oh. Oh, never
mind. It's an or there's one that's
similar color.
Give me the right colors and
hack awakening. There you go. But this
one does not work with blink. So there
you go. Some blast angel. Yes. This is
sweet. I think that's it.
Magnus does not work with blink. It
works with slow blink. So
no mojin doesn't
work. But some blast is sweet. Okay. I'm
very happy about finding sunlast.
Sunblast. Just last minute checking is
there any other synergy. We're at 64
cards, so we have room for maybe one or
two more
cards. Treasure. Treasure synergy. No.
Lifelink. Gain life
synergy. We We'll do a quick check.
Whenever you gain
life because we can gain life pretty
consistently with today. We gain
life. Oh, well of lost dreams. Is that
worth
playing? Might be not this. Not this.
Not
this. Whenever you gain life. Whenever
you gain life. Well of lost
dreams. So you blink something on your
main face. You attack. you pay a lot of
mana
to. It's really mana intensive, but late
game might just get you back into the
game. It's Is it better than Mind's Eye?
Is it better than Minds? I think it's
better. And there's some synergy. So,
I'm going
to We'll have to test this one. I'll
have to test. But I think that's it for
life gang
synergy. No game. D of hope gain gain
draw our card draw a card whenever you
gain life is not good enough
um
yeah exemplar of
light whenever you gain life put no it's
too slow I think because we're not we're
not even guaranteed one liking a
turn whenever you gain life put that
many counters on it's decent boom is
that was two
No. Uh, let me double check. Dawn of
hope. What is What's the other
ability? H. Create a one- one white
soldier
creature. It's like a mana
sync. It's like a mana
sync,
but to use it, you have to basically
sacrifice it, attack, and then pay two.
I don't think it's good enough. Okay,
last. We probably need more removals
like whatever cards we we eventually
find to be not pulling the weight, we
will switch what switch for more
interaction. But for now, we'll just
make sure to think of let's think of are
there any lands that can work with today
aside from homework
path link and
haste lands that work with
today? High market of
course
because some creatures we just want to
kill. High
mark. We are 2 hours 30 minutes into the
video. I'm holding up. Okay. My voice is
hurting a little bit but like my voice
was hurting and then now it's not
hurting anymore. I'm not sure. This
can't be good. But but we are dedicated.
Hi market and uh something something
mine.
Okay. No,
no. Advanced
search. It's called something. Mine
field. Cory. Cororey. Cory. There you
go. Lazep
quy. Uh, sack creature.
Yeah. What else can we sack creature
with? I'm going to just search for all
lens that interact with creature.
Can't be too many, right? Can't be too
many. Land creature boros
go path. No, no, no, no. Saga searches
for no cavern souls.
No. Sure, we can play some utility
lines,
but do we play maze
of is that good? It's
not access tunnel. Nope. Draw a
card. Make a token. We do want some mana
sinks just because we are playing with a
lot of mana open, right? because we plot
a creature down and then we hold mana
and sometimes often times we only need
one creature on the field to to control
the game. We need one creature like for
examp mana and play
reactively. Speaking of playing
reactively, do we have enough ways to
finish the
game? Maybe we need another maybe
another finisher or something.
This molten primordial is okay, but
okay, we'll look at lens first. Oh, this
is a great card. Yeah, this is
excellent. You can blink it. Oh, your
attack.
Nope. My moria man. Sure. Yeah, we're
not going to do Oh, tail talon
gates. You know what? This goes into an
earlier deck. So, it goes into what's
his name?
The landfall the the the the amulet blow
commander minstrol. Yes, because you can
keep using it, reusing it over and over.
Yeah.
Okay. Sh. Yeah. Protection spell is
always
good. Haven arcane. Do we want plus two
vigilance? Nope. Do we want to make
tokens? Yes, we
do.
Okay. Mut vault.
No, I think that's it for
lands. Think that's
it. Okay. And now we need wind
condition. What's a Boro's wind
condition? I guess
insurrection. And there's synergy with
it. So I guess we play insurrection.
[Music]
spreading
insurrection. No. And also just one
more. What's that one that double strike
and goes everything? That card is good,
too. We're just messing with combat
here. Double strike go. Spectacular
showdown. Yes. Yeah. And now we are at
74 cards, but it's mostly lands that
we're missing. Yeah, this deck is again,
I'm really excited for this. I might
actually build this, but we have to move
on to the next legendary. We are 2 hours
and 36 minutes in.
Okay, so as you can see, after some
brainstorming, now we have a deck that
uses sedane and blink spells to shut
down combat for your opponents. It will
be really difficult to attack into this
setup when your opponents know that you
have 10 to 15 blink spells in your deck.
And at the same time, we hold the fort
and slowly take over the game with other
ETB creatures. And this deck again
sounds like a blast to play. I will
actually build it and test it. And right
now, there's a tentative list on the
bottom of all the decks I brainstormed
in the descriptions, but later if enough
people are interested, I might do a an
updated deck tech and along with a deck
list for this. So yeah, please like and
subscribe and let me know what kind of
content you like. I'm trying lots of
different things and yeah, just let me
know what you look forward to seeing
more in the future. Thanks.